[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unbox today we're
taking a look at Intel's new arc a 580
the newest member of the arc a series
based on the alchemus GPU architecture
essentially what you're getting here is
all the same modern features that you
get with the a750 such as av1 encoding
XE SS support and R tracing but at a
more affordable price point so that's a
bit exciting but before we get into it
today's video is sponsored by Asus and
their fantastic Rog stricks XG 27 aqm R
gaming monitor if you're after a 27-in
1440p display with super fast 300 HZ
capabilities look no further than the XG
27 aqm packing variable overdrive and
excellent response time tuning this IPS
LCD monitor offers great motion Clarity
for everything from fast-paced
multiplayer games to the latest AAA
Blockbuster Busters in our review we
also found it to be quite a versatile
display with impressive color accuracy
and a decent range of color controls all
at a mid-range price point to learn more
about the Asus XG 27 aqr click the link
in the description below okay so while
the a580 is going to be more affordable
than the a750 it's also going to be
slower but hopefully not too much slower
and without question it's going to be
much faster than the horribly slow A380
that we looked at a year ago now as it's
much closer to the a750 in terms of
specs given that it does share the same
silicon along with the
a770 so in short the a580 packs 372
Shader units 192 tmus and 96 DRS so
that's 14% fuer Shad units and rs when
compared to the a750 but the same number
of tmus and as a side note there's three
times more Shader units tmus and rs than
the
A380 another downgrade though when
compared to the a750 includes a 33%
reduction in L2 cache capacity with just
8 megabytes but other than that they are
very similar in fact the a580 a750 and 8
GB a770 all feature the same memory
configuration down to the Last Detail
that means the a580 comes with 8 GB of
gddr6 memory operating at 16 GB per
second on a 256bit wide memory bus for a
bandwidth of 500 12 GB per second the
a580 also supports the fulltime 16 PCI
4.0 interface and features a TDP of
175 Watts so in terms of performance it
shouldn't be that much slower than the
a750 which is a good thing given that
Intel has set the MSRP at $180 us just
$40 us less than what you can currently
purchase the a75 for so it works out to
be an almost 20% discount now the focus
for this compar though won't be with the
a750 rather the more relevant
competition in the radon RX 6600 and I
guess the GeForce RTX
350 the RX 6600 is particularly relevant
given that it can be had for $210 right
now whereas the most affordable RTX GPU
so the RTX 350 that generally costs
quite a bit more though I am seeing
quite a lot of models dropping down
around $230 us at the moment that said
we know that the RTX 3050 is generally
slower than the RX 6600 so even at $230
us it's not going to be a great deal
anyway as it stands the a580 key
competitors here are the RX 6600 and RTX
350 so let's see how they compare now
normally for a review I would include
more than a dozen gpus for comparison
but for this one I didn't have that much
time to work with so I decided to test a
range of newer games comparing the a580
66350 and that means all of the data for
this content is 100% fresh and of course
for testing we are using our AMD ryzen 7
7800x 3D test system with 32 GB of ddr5
6 cr30 memory the latest display drivers
were used for all three gpus and
resizable bar was enabled as that's the
default setting for this Hardware
configuration in total we have a dozen
games to go over tested at both 1080P
and 1440p along with some overclocking
and power consumption figures as well so
let's get into
it first up we have the of as part one
and this isn't a particularly favorable
showing for the arc gpus and this is
true in particular for the a580 as it
managed just 41 FPS at 1080P and 19 FPS
at 1440p using the high preset and Intel
does claim that this is a high quality
1080p gaming GPU but in this comparison
the RTX 3050 was 20% faster at 108p
while the RX 6600 was a massive 44%
faster so that's pretty bad for Intel I
should note though that Intel says they
have addressed the poor Arc performance
in The Last of Us Part One with their
October 4th driver release though sadly
for whatever reason those fixers didn't
make it into the a 580s release driver
bit of an oversight there but they claim
the next a580 driver will include those
fixers next we have the very popular
Boulders Gate 3 and here the a580 is
much more competitive though it did
suffer a few minor frame pacing issues
when compared to the RX 6600 generally
speaking though performance overall was
similar between these two gpus allowing
the a580 to beat the RTX 3050 by a
rather substantial 29%
margin the a580 was also competitive in
Resident Evil 4 beating the RTX 350 by a
177% margin at 10dp while coming in just
10% slower than the RX 6600 so not a bad
result overall and 75 FPS at 1080p using
the prioritized graphic quality preset
is a good result I'd say moving on to
the Kalisto protocol we find more highly
competitive results from the a580 here
it is able to match the RX 6600 at both
tester resolutions making it 22% faster
than the RTX 350 so again this is a
great result for
Intel now another rather awful title for
Arc is Starfield and here things are
really bad and this one does highlight a
problem with the Intel Arc gpus that
said while performance for the a580 is
just awful here Intel's again claim that
performance here has been addressed with
the latest driver but again those fixes
just weren't included in the a580
release driver which again it's just a
massive oversight in my opinion in any
case we've seen a lot of these issues
with The Arc gpus and while performance
can be excellent like what we saw in the
previous two titles it can also tank to
the point of being completely unusable
and that's certainly the case here the
RX 6600 was good for 47 FPS at 1080p
using the medium quality preset while
the a580 could only must 16 FPS so
there's really not much more that needs
to be said about that that isn't already
obvious interestingly Ratchet and Clank
Rift depart is a super title for the
a580 here it straight up murdered the RX
6600 and RTX 350 delivering 32% more
frames at 1080P and 45% more at 40 and
40p in fact these results were so good I
had to go back and check all three gpus
but results are right I think it's fair
to say that based on the D size and
power usage which we will look at in a
moment I can't help but feel we should
be seeing more of this from the AR gpus
like the
a580 here we see that Intel's new $180
us GPU is impressive relative to the
radon and GeForce competition in Star
Wars Jedi Survivor smashing the RTX 3050
by a 23% margin at 1080p to deliver RX
6600 live performance so a great result
here Hitman 3 is another strong title
for the a580 here it again matched the
RX 6600 at 10p and even Beat It by 10%
margin at 1440p with an impressive and
very playable 75 FPS on
average the f123 performance was a
little underwhelming but even so the
a580 performance overall was good with
121 FPS at 10p and 95 FPS at 440p which
placed it roughly on par with the RTX
3050 particularly at the higher 1440p
resolution it was also 20% slower than
the RX 6600 at 1080p but as I said
performance overall was still good the
for of horizon 5 results are solid the
a580 was closer to the RX 6600 than it
was the RTX 350 at 1080p with 88 FPS on
average that made it 15% slower than the
RX 6600 but 24% faster than the RTX 3050
then at 1440p it was 31% faster than the
RT TX 350 and the additional memory
bandwidth allowed it to match the RX
6600 the a580 was very impressive when
testing with cyber Punk 2077 Phantom
Liberty here it edged out the RX 6600 at
10p and Beat It by a 19% margin at 1440p
that also made it 31% faster than the
RTX 350 at 1080P and a massive 42%
faster at
440p and last up we have Spider-Man
remastered and again the a580 is very
impressive here beating the RX 6600 by a
4% margin at 1080P and 11% at 1440p
therefore as you'd expect based on that
it easily beat the RTX
3050 okay so here's a look at the 12
game average which includes the very
poor performance scen in The Last of Us
Part One and Starfield Which Intel
claims will be addressed with the next
driver update for the a580 to what
degree though we will have to wait for
that upcoming driver to find out so
based on that data though the A5 80 was
12% slower than the RX 6600 which isn't
too bad given that it should be around
14% cheaper but we'll talk more about
that soon the good news is it was 10%
faster than the RTX 3050 which I guess
is good news for Intel though it more
highlights just how trash to the RTX
3050 is and always has been so I guess
there's that then at 1440p the a580 was
9% slower than the RX 6600 and 12%
faster than the RTX 350 so that's pretty
good but with Intel claiming to be
addressing the performance scene in The
Last of Us Part One and Starfield you
could say this data misrepresents the
a58 despite the fact that it doesn't and
as things stand the data is accurate
we've also seen more examples in the
past where AR gpus struggle more than
they probably should but for argument
sake let's say that including the data
is unfair so let's remove it here's the
10 game average with The Last of Us Part
One and Starfield removed now the a58
and RX 6600 neck and neck at 1080p
making the a580 a massive 22% faster
than the RTX 350 so that's a ride off
for NVIDIA then at 1440p Intel's new arc
GPU was 7% faster than the RX 6600 and
30% faster than the RTX 350 so a great
set of results there for the
a580 okay time for some RT benchmarks
and here we see when enabling rad
tracing a resent Evil 4 with the R
Racing preset that the a580 was good for
66 FPS on average 1080p making it 6%
faster than the RX 6600 and 18% faster
than the RTX 350 so a great result there
for benchmarking with s Punk 2077
Phantom Liberty I used the medium R
tracing preset and that was a bit much
for these gpus even when factoring in
the possibility of using upscaling the
a580 does well relative to the
competition just beating the RTX 350 but
overall performance was horrible then
the last game I looked at with r tracing
enabled is is Spider-Man remastered and
here all three gpus do very well the
a580 was comparable to both the RTX 350
and RX 6600 so a good result
overall unfortunately though a big
weakness of the a580 is power
consumption and there are a few issues
here firstly when compared to the Radeon
and GeForce competition you're looking
at a 35% increase in power usage for our
test system when using the a580 that's a
massive increase we're talking around 80
wats more for often less performance so
that's pretty bad but possibly worse
than that was the at least 50% increase
in idle power draw jumping up from
around 80 to 90 wats with the RX 6600
and RTX 350 to almost 130 wats with the
a580 so that's a problem and I'm not
sure if intel can address it with a
future driver update but hopefully they
can now just quickly here's a look at
the overclocking performance of our
sample stock it was typically observed
operating at 2.4 GHz and I was able to
raise that to 2.6 GHz without
compromising stability again this is
just a sample size of one so the typical
overclocking potential of the a580 is
unknown at this point in time anyway
with our overclock testing with
cyberpunk it only showed an increase of
a few frames suggesting that core clock
speed wasn't the primary performance
limiting factor here but if we look at
Hitman 3 we see a much more impressive
11 to 12% increase depending on the
resolution so that's pretty decent of
course you can also overclock the RX
6600 and RTX 3050 to varying degrees
depending on the Silicon quality so this
isn't a big win for the
a580 then we're looking at a more mild 6
to 10% uplift depending on the
resolution with Spider-Man remastered so
about what you'd typically expect to see
from this sort of mild
overclock and just lastly as I mentioned
earlier due to the time crunch I
couldn't add loads of gpus to this
content but I did throw in the RX 7600
RTX 460 and a750 for a few quick tests
tests just so you have some kind of
reference point to those products at 10p
and f123 the a580 was 14% slow the a750
30% slower than the RTX 460 and 37%
slower than the RX
7600 right now you can reliably purchase
an RX 7600 for $250 us making the a580
about 28% cheaper so in this one example
the RD3 base 7600 is much better value
especially if you want a game at 14
40p however the a580 was more
competitive in Hitman 3 and here it's
just 9% slower than the a750 at 1080P
and 12% slower at 1440p so that's good
because at $180 us it will be almost 20%
cheaper than the current a750 pricing
then when compared to the RX 7600 it was
20% slower at 1080P and 26% slower than
the RTX 460 so in this example it's
decent value next to those newer AMD and
Nvidia models
so there you have it Intel's newest AR
GPU the
a580 and $180 us I'd say it's it's not
bad certainly not amazing but it's not
bad and as far as GPU reviews go this
year it's actually pretty good I guess
the first question though that well the
first question you might have is should
you actually buy it and the answer to
that is kind of a long- winded it
depends with most paths unfortunately
leading us to conclude that yeah nah you
probably shouldn't buy it the problems
with the a580 are as follows it requires
resizable but work correctly and proper
resizable bar support can be an issue
for older systems the kind of systems
that are probably in need of a new sub
$200 us graphics card but if you can
address the need for Rizal or bar
support another issue might be power
consumption compared to theadi on RX
6600 for example the a580 was generally
slower while consuming significantly
more power so that might be a problem
for you there's also the issue of
performance and while quite good for the
most part we've often found that Arc
gpus can be a bit inconsistent to be
fair to Intel though they have been
demonstrating a strong commitment to
making Arc better over the past year and
appear to be working as hard as ever to
make the project work so while I'm
confident they will continue to improve
here generally speaking at this point in
time it's a safer bet to go with a
Radeon or GeForce G at least in my
opinion and keeping all of that in mind
I'm not sure the a580 is going to be
cheap enough at $180 us given that RX
6600s are sitting at $210 us right now
and while that does mean that the arc
GPU offers a nice 14% discount for what
is often similar performance when things
are working as expected I think you'd
want at minimum that kind of discount
given the drawbacks just mentioned for
example I often say that rad on gpus
need to be at least 15% cheaper than
their GeForce competitors as they often
consume more power are much weaker for
rage racing and FSR at this point in
time is an inferior upscaling and frame
generation technology to that of dlss
but amd's radon display drivers have
been excellent for us with the rdna2 and
three generations arguably better than
nvidia's as we've had far fewer issues
with multim monitor setups as one
example in short though if I were given
the option of owning and gaming with
either the a580 at $180 or the RX 6600
at $210 I'd go with the radon GPU every
time and in fact I'd probably check out
the RX 7600 as some models have dropped
as low as $240 us now and that's a
pretty great price for that product and
it's also a more usable product in my
opinion despite the 8 GB vram limitation
the ark 580 is certainly a decent
offering at $180 us I think it's fair to
say it's far from bad but also I'm just
not sure that I'm ready to roll the dice
at Intel just yet as I said they have
come a long way in a relatively short
period of time so good work Intel but
there is also more work to be done
before I'd part with my money and that
is where I'm going to leave this one if
you enjoyed the video give it a thumbs
up subscribe for more content and if
you'd like some more Harbor unbox
goodness then check us out over at float
plan or patreon sign up to either one of
those things you will get access to our
exclusive Discord server ever so for
members only pretty cool place to hang
out talk check and other stuff we also
do a monthly live stream Tim and myself
get together and do that behind the
scenes content Q&A stuff lot of cool
things there worth checking out if
you're interested I suppose but if not
that is perfectly fine and I would like
to thank you for watching this video I'm
your host Steve see you again next
[Music]
time